esperanza eso es lo que se respira en
chile estos días todas estas personas de
la tercera edad del barrio obrero de la
florida en las afueras de santiago que
llegan en buses siguiendo una pauta de
organización viven con esperanza el
ansiado momento de recibir al fin una
primera dosis de la vacuna el estadio de
la florida es el mayor de chile
habilitado para este propósito y recibe
a unas seis mil personas diarias
siguiendo el calendario de vacunación
por edades para mí en terrible para mí
se murió mi familia murieron primo murió
mucha gente de mi familia y tuve familia
muy cercana que tuvo el hobby y vecinos
también ya toda esa gente de donde yo
vivo quisiera no sé cómo expresarme para
decirle que se vacuna tras vacunarse
maría espera recuperar su vida ir a su
club pero a sus nietos no es la única
pero obvio si lo único que quiero es
que seamos libres y el programa de
inoculación por kobe en este centro de
llamadas también de la municipalidad de
la florida se reciben las solicitudes de
vacunas a domicilio para aquellas
personas muy mayores o que no pueden
desplazarse
enriqueta y su madre sean y van a
recibir la vacuna
la hija puede hacerlo como cuidadora de
su madre oferta de 97 años
si se puede salir quiero irme a la playa
quiero salir quiero llevarla a algún
lado porque de verdad que esto es estar
encerrada a uno la tiene verlo mal
y con la preocupación de no contagiarse
y por qué no ir de compras al molde la
actividad favorita de los chilenos y de
paso vacunarse en una asociación
público-privada el mall plaza egaña de
santiago ofrece vacunación sin bajarse
de su auto y la diferencia
principalmente que aquí nosotros podemos
acceder a mayor población si porque hoy
día también necesitamos vacunar a la
mayor población que podamos
tras situarse como líder en vacunación
en la región entre los 10 mejores del
mundo y sorprender a todos con la
velocidad de su ritmo chile empieza a
ver la luz al final del túnel de la era
kobe